Caption: good afternoon my name is david martin
Caption: and i'm talking today about extra asx
Caption: trading versus machine learning ml ops
Caption: by accident
Caption: first though i'd like to say thanks to
Caption: the sponsors for allowing us to have
Caption: this conference it's a great opportunity
Caption: so the other thing i'd like to open with
Caption: is this is not financial advice please
Caption: don't rush out get a comsec account and
Caption: blow next month's rate rent or your
Caption: mortgage i'll get in trouble for
Caption: that so why why am i here
Caption: for me my machine learning journey
Caption: started with the new york city taxi fare
Caption: prediction project
Caption: so i found that on the microsoft website
Caption: back in late 2019 and what it let me do
Caption: was it lets me um
Caption: experience machine learning with c-sharp
Caption: in a very easy uh and comfortable way
Caption: and
Caption: a taxi fare is an easy thing to predict
Caption: it's the name of the taxi company the
Caption: distance traveled
Caption: time of day so and so forth and what i
Caption: could see from that without teaching the
Caption: code
Caption: anything at all it could read this data
Caption: file and make predictions from it so
Caption: straight away i could see
Caption: i was interested i was interested by the
Caption: subject but also that code could learn
Caption: something and so i was quite fascinated
Caption: by that
Caption: the thing was
Caption: in my experience that project was it was
Caption: i was hard coded so every time i wanted
Caption: to add a new feature remove a feature
Caption: make an alteration i had to change the
Caption: code and recompile and i wondered
Caption: if there was a way to
Caption: dynamically change it so i could upload
Caption: any
Caption: data sets with different features and
Caption: data points and see if it could just
Caption: test it and use it and predict from it
Caption: so
Caption: what i ended up doing was i end up
Caption: building a tool for myself and i've
Caption: called it data shark
Caption: what it let me do was create data files
Caption: upload them and it didn't know in
Caption: advance what they were it could go
Caption: through
Caption: and test all the permutations of of data
Caption: and
Caption: machine learning parameters and find the
Caption: most optimized solution for me so it
Caption: could test hundreds and thousands of
Caption: models for hours completely
Caption: automatically so once i'd achieved that
Caption: i was quite satisfied with it i tested
Caption: it with healthcare data i'm from the
Caption: healthcare sector i've been public
Caption: health now for about 17 odd years
Caption: i test on a variety of models cancer
Caption: models breast cancer that sort of thing
Caption: and i found
Caption: uh i was happy with it but it wasn't
Caption: really um as successful i hoped
Caption: so i decided to pivot to fintech which
Caption: is a passion of mine i've
Caption: studied in finance financial planning so
Caption: i thought i'd combine iot with finance
Caption: and go into asx trading and see if i
Caption: could use machine learning and try and
Caption: work out the features that i needed to
Caption: be able to predict a trade in advance
Caption: which brings me to today
Caption: so my agenda for this talk is the first
Caption: part of it is my trading strategy what
Caption: trading strategy was i going to use or
Caption: model in machine learning
Caption: the second component i want to cover
Caption: today is machine learning in a minute i
Caption: just want to cover some quick
Caption: calculations and
Caption: just so you have an appreciation of how
Caption: it all fits together
Caption: and
Caption: the key part of the talk is ml ops or
Caption: machine learning operations and that's
Caption: how
Caption: having these hundreds of thousands of
Caption: models how i deploy them destroy them
Caption: how they're used at scale and
Caption: automatically because after all my one
Caption: man band and at the end if this time a
Caption: a quick anecdote about my experience so
Caption: far
Caption: so let's start asx
Caption: so i have my own self-managed super fund
Caption: and part of my
Caption: need is to automate that trading look
Caption: for opportunities and trade them
Caption: automatically if possible at the very
Caption: least bring them to my attention
Caption: just like everyone else busy person with
Caption: things to do
Caption: the first thing to consider with share
Caption: trading is it's
Caption: shares are not traded in fact it's
Caption: information and sentiment it's how you
Caption: feel how people feel about a company you
Caption: may feel more comfortable buying say cba
Caption: shares versus
Caption: a small startup you may not have heard
Caption: of before or seen on twitter somewhere
Caption: so it's important to remember that
Caption: information and sentiment is what drives
Caption: trading behavior the buying and selling
Caption: of shares
Caption: and because sentiment or emotion drives
Caption: trading um for for a lot of people then
Caption: volatility which is emotion based equals
Caption: opportunity
Caption: so what that meant was i had to find a
Caption: an event a repeatable reliable event i
Caption: could use and try and predict when that
Caption: event would be successful in a trade so
Caption: in my particular case or the strategy i
Caption: formed was around asx announcements asx
Caption: announcements are documents that
Caption: accompanies obliged to notify the market
Caption: of certain events good and good news and
Caption: bad news
Caption: and so my strategy
Caption: the strategy that i developed or devised
Caption: was
Caption: to predict when an asx announcement from
Caption: a company would move the share price up
Caption: by a certain amount so let's say 10 15
Caption: percent well let's say 15
Caption: and then that way we can turn that into
Caption: a binary machine learning model did it
Caption: move over 15 or did it not and so that
Caption: way we can attack
Caption: the trading strategy by using binary
Caption: classification and machine learning
Caption: which brings me to the next part data
Caption: so data as i said they're making the
Caption: model so the data that i've considered
Caption: when supporting
Caption: these decisions these machine learning
Caption: models is announcement metadata the time
Caption: of day
Caption: the day of the week the month of the
Caption: year so and so forth season if you
Caption: wanted to these are all things i've
Caption: factored and experimented with before
Caption: the title of the document the company
Caption: came from are all valid choices as
Caption: features
Caption: the other thing i experimented with was
Caption: uh sentiment so there's microservice
Caption: available from ibm azure google that you
Caption: can do sentiment scoring and i did that
Caption: on the asx announcement titles and used
Caption: that as a feature as well in my my
Caption: modeling
Caption: another thing to consider i talked about
Caption: sentiment before so twitter twitter
Caption: twitter's a great place for our day
Caption: traders news articles regularly
Caption: published a few hundred a day during the
Caption: trading week the volume of those
Caption: announcements the sentiment of those uh
Caption: statements themselves they're good or
Caption: bad and capturing those can help
Caption: determine the uh the volatility of the
Caption: movement of a stock
Caption: another good example you've probably
Caption: seen the tv is economic indicators
Caption: inflation data you've probably heard
Caption: about jobs numbers you've heard about
Caption: rba interest decision which affects a
Caption: lot of us with mortgages
Caption: those are all good features and factors
Caption: that i've considered before in my models
Caption: the other thing to consider is trading
Caption: data derivatives so moving averages are
Caption: very common you'll see them if anyone
Caption: has a trading account five-day moving
Caption: average 20-day moving average 1500 so
Caption: and so forth so those things i've
Caption: considered my modeling also short
Caption: positions um
Caption: if you're feeling the movie big short or
Caption: any of those things it that also drives
Caption: sentiment you can see what other people
Caption: believe if the company's gonna go up or
Caption: down
Caption: next thing i'd like to cover is machine
Caption: learning in a minute
Caption: the first particular calculation is
Caption: confusion matrix now confusion matrix
Caption: i've written there is a performance
Caption: measurement for machine learning
Caption: classification problems where the apple
Caption: can be one or more two classes in my
Caption: case it's a binary classification
Caption: problem so it's very simple true false
Caption: as you can see from the sample confusion
Caption: matrix i've got there the predicted
Caption: positive
Caption: is where the machine learning model has
Caption: predicted that it's going to happen now
Caption: on the left hand side you can see actual
Caption: positive now actual positive is where in
Caption: fact the machine said yes and it did
Caption: happen the next one below the actual
Caption: negative is where the machine said yes
Caption: but it didn't happen
Caption: moving on from there is precision now
Caption: specifically with
Caption: um
Caption: precision it's important that
Caption: left-handed column is all the trades we
Caption: would make because we don't know in
Caption: advance whether or not the trade is
Caption: going to be successful or unsuccessful
Caption: and that is the price moves more than 15
Caption: and achieves our objective
Caption: so in order to measure a model's uh
Caption: accuracy while it's being trained and
Caption: tested
Caption: we use the calculation called precision
Caption: and you can see i put a sample there
Caption: using the numbers from the previous
Caption: confusion matrix so true positive on the
Caption: top and the true positive false positive
Caption: on the bottom so as you can see from the
Caption: score there point to weight
Caption: approximately 28 percent
Caption: so the question asks is it a good model
Caption: to trade with and the answer is no
Caption: what it's saying there is 28 of your
Caption: trades would be success which means
Caption: approximately 70 wouldn't be and there's
Caption: a good chance you're losing money now
Caption: the the thing that's important to point
Caption: out here is that at a 15 target the
Caption: share price could have gone up five or
Caption: ten percent but not our goal of 15 so
Caption: it's still considered a fail
Caption: or not a good trade
Caption: so moving on from there ml ops the
Caption: necessary accident the situation i had
Caption: was the the tool i built was building
Caption: thousands hundreds of thousands of
Caption: models how could i determine the good
Caption: ones to send out and deploy to
Caption: production and test
Caption: and then equally dispose of them and the
Caption: need
Caption: was to automate all of that i'm a
Caption: one-man band and there's hundreds of
Caption: thousands of models i couldn't develop
Caption: apis for each model they were deployed i
Caption: couldn't manually deploy or destroy them
Caption: that sort of thing i had to make it
Caption: completely automated so any future model
Caption: that's deployed i submit my criteria was
Caption: automatically deployed
Caption: so i invented yet another tool this one
Caption: i decided to call scarborough fare as a
Caption: marketplace now as any marketplace it
Caption: has market rules
Caption: i decided that
Caption: one of the minimum criteria was a
Caption: confidence score now every machine
Caption: learning prediction has a confidence how
Caption: confident is the model that the
Caption: prediction is accurate
Caption: i started off with a sixty percent
Caption: accuracy rate so if the model was sixty
Caption: percent sure the the
Caption: the prediction was going to be
Caption: successful or positive
Caption: then i would score the precision that
Caption: way and deploy that model to production
Caption: and that's the bid i named market maker
Caption: so that's the continuous delivery so
Caption: those models if they met my criteria
Caption: were deployed to
Caption: production the next place i've named cd
Caption: plus is in the devops sort of paradigm
Caption: so cd plus is the continuous deployment
Caption: continuous deployment meant the model
Caption: was immediately exposed to production
Caption: data in real time without me lifting a
Caption: finger
Caption: so the idea of building a api that could
Caption: know the features the model needed in
Caption: advance and simply provide them to the
Caption: model and in return the model gave back
Caption: a prediction hence the idea of a
Caption: marketplace where one thing is traded
Caption: for another
Caption: the next component was what i've called
Caption: the market taker
Caption: now deploy models to productions
Caption: thousands of them obviously that becomes
Caption: a scalability problem after time what
Caption: you want to be able to test those models
Caption: and say it does not meet my standards of
Caption: of quality or the amount of predictions
Caption: i'm getting i want to remove it from
Caption: production and make way for the next
Caption: candidate
Caption: to accelerate that process i created a
Caption: backtester
Caption: or the ci part of ci cd
Caption: the idea being that every data set i use
Caption: to make my models is 120 days uh sorry
Caption: the end of the data model is 128 day 120
Caption: days before today the idea being that
Caption: when the model is deployed to production
Caption: every night i can run the last 120 days
Caption: of data through all the models that are
Caption: in production what that allows me to do
Caption: is accelerate the failure rate to one
Caption: night or 24 hours
Caption: i can run four months of data and i'll
Caption: know within 24 hours what it would have
Caption: done in four months
Caption: and i can dispose the model far quicker
Caption: than waiting the four months
Caption: so the problem with this automation is
Caption: it's literally coming going like an ex
Caption: like a
Caption: transit station and i don't know what's
Caption: going on so what i decided to do was
Caption: build a twitter account
Caption: and through the what scarborough affair
Caption: does is as it deploys models to
Caption: production and disposes of them it
Caption: tweets to a locked account and also when
Caption: it predicts so i can see what's going on
Caption: and occasionally i'll scroll through
Caption: that so just to demonstrate what i've
Caption: done so far
Caption: model dispose so that's the model being
Caption: disposed in production you can see there
Caption: no predictions over the last 120 days
Caption: and so it has been disposed of
Caption: there's another example and this is
Caption: where it's less than 60 accurate over
Caption: the last 120 days
Caption: and again this would have been disposed
Caption: of after it was tested
Caption: conversely a model deploy now model
Caption: deploys when scarborough affair is
Caption: determined one of the models being
Caption: has been
Caption: invented developed is worthy of
Caption: deployment you can see there the
Caption: precision score is high it's in fact
Caption: perfect it's set to a one
Caption: and that's been deployed so i've quickly
Caption: got some stats there that i want when
Caption: it's tweeted out
Caption: and then the whole reason we're doing
Caption: this is a prediction so there's a sample
Caption: prediction there so you can see it's put
Caption: in the model number the confidence score
Caption: in this particular case is set to 0.7
Caption: in recent months i've set my confidence
Caption: score to 0.8 and i won't accept anything
Caption: less than that
Caption: so this is an older one
Caption: you can see there though it's given the
Caption: announcement the time of the
Caption: announcement and the website it relates
Caption: to the idea being that i can follow the
Caption: trade and see if it actually plays out
Caption: the way the computer's predicted
Caption: the next thing i built myself was a a
Caption: trading desk a screen of sorts that
Caption: shows me all the models as you can see
Caption: there so the top list is some of the
Caption: models in production that i've got
Caption: deployed the first column there is the
Caption: true positive that we discussed before
Caption: so there where the computer has said
Caption: there will be successful trade and in
Caption: fact there was false positive you can
Caption: see are all zeros but again with the
Caption: computer would have said yes trade and
Caption: we would have lost money potentially
Caption: and then uh false negative and true
Caption: negative
Caption: so true negative is when there was no
Caption: trading opportunity and a false negative
Caption: is a missed opportunity now i don't
Caption: particularly focus on that column very
Caption: overspilled milk we look at the
Caption: opportunities where we would have put
Caption: money on the table but the false
Caption: negative is good to see
Caption: how many opportunities we miss out on
Caption: you can see the last two columns there
Caption: percentage is those two facts
Caption: below that in the table below you can
Caption: see i've selected the last
Caption: last model and there's two
Caption: two predictions it's made i've
Caption: deliberately uh whited out the asx code
Caption: so no one gets any ideas
Caption: you can see from that the details the
Caption: time the title
Caption: the probability
Caption: or the confidence level of the model the
Caption: opening and closing price and what it
Caption: played out to be so you can see in those
Caption: cases it's 16 and 17 respectively so in
Caption: this case it was a successful trade if
Caption: we in fact had executed them
Caption: so
Caption: i've been tracking that now for a um a
Caption: couple of months but before
Caption: that all happened
Caption: um
Caption: there was a period of time where
Caption: i built this and deployed this and not a
Caption: single model was produced not one had
Caption: met
Caption: met my criteria and i think this period
Caption: of time was about two months
Caption: and i was nervous was i wrong was i
Caption: completely wrong were the maths wrong
Caption: was my theory wrong
Caption: and so there was there was a long period
Caption: of time where i really questioned
Caption: whether i'd gone off on a weird tangent
Caption: and i was wrong and then what i found
Caption: was
Caption: after about two months models started to
Caption: be deployed so through all these data
Caption: sets i tested all these different
Caption: features moving average economic
Caption: indicators
Caption: and models started to meet that that
Caption: criterion be deployed
Caption: and i went through and looked at the top
Caption: one and the top one actually had a
Caption: fantastic accuracy rate had 70 percent
Caption: success sorry 70 right and seven wrong
Caption: seven wrong opportunities fantastic
Caption: school never seen it before i thought it
Caption: was worth investigating what had it
Caption: picked
Caption: and what i discovered was it had picked
Caption: a particular concept as what we call a
Caption: speeding ticket in the trading world and
Caption: a speeding ticket is when a company
Caption: moves
Caption: outside its normal price and volume
Caption: parameters so when that happens the asx
Caption: notices that anomaly and will write a
Caption: letter to the to the board of the
Caption: company
Caption: in case there's been a leak of
Caption: information or something like that and
Caption: say do you have an explanation for this
Caption: movement um
Caption: price movement or volume movement and as
Caption: you can see there i put up a sample of a
Caption: letter there that was given to a company
Caption: a couple of months ago and you can see
Caption: from the title the top line highlighted
Caption: price and volume query it's a very
Caption: common document
Caption: plenty come out days weeks all the time
Caption: and what the machine learning model had
Caption: discovered was when this this title of
Caption: this document comes out the price moves
Caption: now unfortunately this document comes
Caption: out after the price moves so it's not a
Caption: tradable opportunity but what it
Caption: demonstrated to me was
Caption: that it learned something it learned
Caption: that when this document is published by
Caption: a company the price will move
Caption: so to me i while i haven't achieved my
Caption: ultimate objective of
Caption: being able to trade successfully on the
Caption: asx it has demonstrated to me that i'm
Caption: on the right path
Caption: um
Caption: so far
Caption: so thanks very much for your time
Caption: and i've just got some resources there
Caption: around some calculations mlops as well
Caption: thanks for your time